we are joined by magnus carlsen after a
very good day
against wesley so magnus how happy are
you with your play today
i was okay um you don't need that
that first game no but the the thing
is that uh um
this knight of six is uh something that
um that wasn't wasn't a file
peter sent me earlier today so uh
obviously if if it had been my idea that
i found found over the board i would be
would be very proud
um obviously i didn't know um
the whole the whole line after after
what happened
um so magnus
i had to i had to figure out some of
that
over the world um but
truth be told it wasn't wasn't very uh
wasn't very
difficult after after f5 uh but still
i mean it's it's a great feeling
obviously to
to be such a good player in in that sort
of style
and yeah i know we have the the the
first game here on your an
analysis of word david um this was
simply spectacular yeah i have to ask
magnus you said this was in your file
this was in your opening preparation but
personally i've never seen this move on
move four before is this
have you revolutionized chess uh
openings with this move
no it's been played i think like by
fun forest i believe and some some
others
um what's the idea behind it it looks so
counterproductive or county intuitive at
least
you grab some space
[Laughter]
sounds so simple yeah definitely
the the thing is you're trying to get a
good version of something
um some opening in in reverse
like after after d5 you're claiming that
a4 is a
is a useful move there um
and also after moves like bishop c5 or
bishop b4
orbish b7 whatever you're trying
trying again to claim that that
that there is use for the move a4
realistically obviously it's not even
close to being better um
but uh yeah the fact that i actually
managed to
um to play he sort of jumped into the
one
line where white has a serious ideas
obviously um pretty fortunate for me but
um still very very satisfying
so magnus did you simply um have fun
playing today without maybe too much
pressure
no i would say i wasn't particularly
motivated for it before
um today but the first game
helped immensely after that
i sort of tried to treat it as uh
as a series match and that i i wanted to
um i i wanted at least not to
score any own goals like i did
on the on the previous day two days now
uh we are following the final game with
uh nepo
and anish can we get your expert
verdict on this strange um position with
very few pieces left
uh i think it's pretty much an ideal
situation
um for for jan here he's way up on
way up in time the scoring the match is
it's equal and
it feels it feels like he has a little
bit of
a pressure at least psychologically
speaking so
i think he he must be pretty pretty
happy
i'm sure the computer spits out
spits out the draw and one or
probably in many ways but yeah it's it's
a lot more pleasant to
to be on here so yeah you i mean i i
agree i would prefer yan's position here
but
if you were a niche on the flip side um
if you had less time and
maybe some passive pieces how would you
approach this position with black
i would try and force matters um
probably that's that's what i would say
okay
he doesn't have he does he have the
right to castle by the way
yes yeah i can't
yeah i was thinking of uh of lines like
age
three here uh and uh
lines like h3 and something like bishop
g5
takes takes and if not for for castle
well there's also rook of fate actually
uh but castle obviously solves all that
all the problems you could have yeah
that's um
costly so late in the game yeah this is
a strange game this is a strange day
i hope you enjoyed it magnus we
certainly did following your games
no a as i said the first game helped
immensely when it came to
to to motivation and um
i mean the other the other match has
been has been fun to
to follow uh follow as well all right we
thank you so much for joining us minus
good luck tomorrow as well
thank you